liebe zuschauer ich wette viele von
ihnen hängen jetzt gerade beim gucken
nebenbei in der warteschleife um
vielleicht doch noch einen impftermin zu
ergattern
tipp von mir einfach auflegen da geht
keiner ran
also jedenfalls nicht im ersten quartal
keine chance keine chance wenn er es ist
wie es ist wir haben zu wenig bestellt
zu spät bestellt zu spät
produktionskapazitäten aufgebaut
klar die meisten fehler wurden von der
eu unter deutscher ratspräsidentschaft
schon im letzten jahr gemacht trotzdem
wäre es ja für unsere psyche wichtig
wenn man das zumindest einmal zu geben
könnte man fragt sich doch was ist denn
da jetzt eigentlich schiefgelaufen
also ich glaube dass im großen ganzen
nichts schief gelaufen ist so akuter
realitätsverlust gibt es da nicht was
von ratiopharm erst hatten wir
monatelang zu wenig masken dann zu wenig
tests und jetzt zu wenig impfdosen was
soll da schief gelaufen sein
abgehakt frau merkel verspricht bis zum
21 september kriegt jeder ein
impfangebot das wird quasi unser impften
stay zufällig genau fünf tage vor der
bundestagswahl wird wir alle gut gelaunt
und frisch geimpft in die wahlkabine
rein tänze immerhin immerhin gab es
diese woche den großen impf gipfel im
kanzleramt
was kann da am ende raus es gibt eine
nationale impfstrategie die ist zwischen
dem bundesgesundheitsminister und den
bundesländern entwickelt worden
diese nationale impfstrategie wird jetzt
auch einen nationalen impfplan enthalten
doch auf ja wir haben zwar keinen
impfstoff aber dafür eine impfstrategie
und jetzt kommt mit einem impfplan drin
wieso ein überraschungsei also der plan
ist noch nicht fertig in dem sinn aber
der ist so gut wie in der post hört mal
in berlin tagt jetzt sogar regelmäßig
ein so genanntes im kabinett wahnsinn
wie viele worte mit impfte hinein fallen
zynismus ist nicht die lösung freunde
und auf eine art sind wir bürger ja auch
mit schuld also es war aus meiner sicht
eigentlich klar dass es knapp sein würde
am anfang und dann ist eine ganz groß
die erwartungshaltung entstanden ja das
ist nämlich das problem ihre
unverschämte erwartungshaltung da
draußen die so erwarten sie überhaupt
geimpft zu werden was glauben sie wer
sie sind
natürlich haben die menschen eine
erwartungshaltung auch weil alle drei
meter diese plakate hängen deutschland
krempelt die ärmel hoch wozu ist kalt
draußen
es bleibt dabei die korona kommunikation
der groko hat jede menge luft nach oben
wenn zb die spd jeden tag die regierung
kritisiert wegen impfen in der sie
selber drin sitzt sogar olaf scholz
normalerweise spitzname prinz valium
vergreift sich plötzlich im ton
die impfstoff bestellung durch die eu
sei so wörtlich richtig scheiße gelaufen
was in brüssel laufe sei die nächste
sauerei und habe keinen bock darauf
ebenfalls wörtlich dass ich der scheiß
jetzt wiederholt kein bock mehr auf den
scheiß mit der scheiße hier was ist er
mit ihm los
ganz einfach wahlkampf es wirklich ein
super signal an die bevölkerung dass die
mieten in der pandemie jetzt schon im
wahlkampfmodus sind dabei regieren die
genossen seit 2013 ununterbrochen mit
sind also natürlich auch
mitverantwortlich für das elfte baguette
absoluter kindergartenalter hat die cdu
das mit dem instant voll unfähig die
rocco aber sind für mich auch coco ja
schon aber alles was doof ist weil die
cdu die stinken und bei der nächsten
wahl holt die spd 15 prozent erst mehr
als sagt man sagt ja wenn diese blüten
waren bleiben mir in erinnerung die
fresse ist baby wenn es schiefläuft
waren es die anderen demnächst im kicker
kinderquatsch mit skb wir müssen meine
damen und herren endlich mal von den
positiv beispielen lernen
die gibt es ja auch bei uns von der
stadt rostock zum beispiel die mit einer
konsequenten pragmatischen corona
strategie nach einem jahr gerade mal 18
tote zu beklagen hat dafür brauchst du
unter anderem viele tests und klare
botschaften
da müssen andere regionen leider erst
noch hinkommen
offenbar hatte bei der kv nordrhein im
vorfeld noch nicht mal jemand die eigene
website auf fehler überprüft sonst wäre
neben den geschlechtern männlich und
weiblich die auswahl taucher wohl nicht
durchgegangen
genau korrekt wäre taucherinnen ist klar
um das mal kurz aufzulösen divers
englisch divers taucher jetzt haben sich
halt sich taucher zum impfen angemeldet
ist halt so sofort was können wir noch
konkret besser machen endlich probleme
beim namen nennen und nicht mehr
weglächeln
wer kann das noch mal am besten lerne so
guten tag
ja genau die ich meine ich die methode
uschi von der leyen kommt hoffentlich
bald an ihr ende
ein skandal jagt den nächsten aber die
gute laune bleibt das mit dem feilschen
beim dosen kaufen war ein historischer
fehler ja unter anderem von ihr
da helfen auch keine impft plattitüde
oder fremdschäm momente wie der hier an
den die taxi nation ist auch change to
get back alive imagine that means i
loved ones
da bekomme ich als puma einen schlimmen
boomer queens oder wie die jungen leute
das nennen und tatsächlich macht die
europäische union machen wir alle gerade
den nächsten katastrophalen fehler kann
demmin besitzt du nur global
leider haben sich aber gerade mal zehn
reiche länder 75 prozent der vorhandenen
dosen gekrallt
wir hocken da wie gollum auf unseren
bestellten vorrat ist eine absolute
katastrophe für die südhalbkugel des
planeten und achtung ein eigentor
wenn das virus in armen ländern
ungestört arbeiten darf kommt es am ende
mutiert zu uns zurück zum beispiel ja
aus afrika nur ein beispiel es gibt also
nur eine lösung den patentschutz
vorübergehend aussetzen damit generika
fabriken in schwellenländern massenhaft
produzieren können oder einfacher
ausgedrückt
es gibt nicht genug kuchen für alle
aber wenn man das rezept haid gäbe es
mehr kuchen
so wir beschlagnahmen das kuchen rezept
fertig und erzählen sie mir nix von
geistigem eigentum
sämtliche impfstoffe basieren auf
grundlagenforschung die wir mit
steuergeld allem an bezahlt haben und
alle frau kuchen für alle das ist die
einzige rettung meiner abgesehen davon
für deutschland brauchen wir vielleicht
gar nicht so viel in figuren wie wir
denken denn bei uns wohnen ja auch
solche leute und die kasse protesten
kommt nicht in frage
traurig nach attila hildmann haben wir
uns auch noch tim mälzer an die
impfgegner verloren
also es gibt jetzt die impfstrategie mit
plan drin toll was noch fehlt ist eine
perspektive wann kommt das leben nachdem
lockdown klar geduld ist wichtig wegen
der mutanten und so aber viele menschen
sind so langsam an ihrer
belastungsgrenze und manche trifft es
natürlich härter als andere geiles
konzept für eine show wir fragen jetzt
jede woche
wem geht es hier eigentlich
angemessensten herzlich willkommen zu
deutschland sucht den von corona am
schlimmsten gekniffenen beruf und hier
ist kandidatin 1 dörte hausten
geschiedene kling dinge die sie arbeitet
als erzieherin in einer kita absolute
als staat
genauso es so beendete cup gewonnen
sciacca seit fünf jahren leitet jetzt
bei unserer kita die altersgruppe schon
vor kohona totaler knochenjob trotzdem
kriegst du natürlich auch viel zurück
burnout zum beispiel alle diese fiesen
hohen stimmen den ganzen tag
[Musik]
ltd fühlt sich irgendwann so an als ob
die räder zum glühenden nagel langsam in
die fanta näherin drückt du möchtest nur
noch schreien und wegrennen
aber wie gesagt man kriegt auch viel
zurück und jetzt halt auch noch cupid
aktuelle ak studie
wer in der kita arbeitet hat ein
besonders hohes infektionsrisiko kriegen
wir dafür eine kostenlose er wirft die
zwei masten oder regelmäßige tests in
allen kitas und deswegen ist es auch ein
guter erfolg das gestern im beschluss
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ganz
klar auch bund und länder den
lehrerinnen und lehrern den
erzieherinnen erzielen aber auch
denjenigen die als pädagogische
fachkräfte in der gesamten
kindertagesbetreuung tätig sind gedankt
haben kann jetzt meine rührung nicht so
zeigen frau ministerin weil ich damit
beschäftigt mir eine kurze
runterzuschlucken ja meine kinder haben
zum dank ein bild von linie mal stimmten
ich hab' ich jemals trotz lockdown kommt
immer noch über ein drittel der plagen
in die kita versteht ja auch alles aber
versuchen sie mal einem
anderthalbjährigen die a-ha regeln zu
erklären oder button ein meter fünfzig
abstand ist also meine erfahrung mit 0
bis 2 jährigen ist diese leute sind
argumenten nicht zugänglich
kurz gesagt für mich brauchst du
entweder nerven aus stahl oder eine
natürliche autorität wie diese
quereinsteigerin steht male auf
und dann macht schüttelt ihr euch mal
ein bisschen und rüttelt euch ein
bisschen dass man wieder schwung rein
kommt und lehre es zwischendurch
langweilig wird weil dies zu klein sein
oder so dann könnt ihr ausgehen ist
nicht schlimm dann kommt ein anderer
rein ja schade dass er nicht so an die
scheuer sagt du an geben dir langweilig
ist hier raus ist kommt man rein
ich denke dass allen klar ihr morgen
niemand ist in dieser pandemie mehr
gekniffen als wir
zeigt mir einen beruf der meere kniffen
ist und hier komplett
kandidat nummer zwei holger stockhaus
profi fußballer in der bundesliga weiter
nicht abwaschen oder damals die ältere
dame hier eben erzählt hat ist ganz
lustig sie beschwert sich dass sie nicht
getestet wird wir profikicker werden
tatsächlich jeden tag getestet und das
ist super unangenehmen man kriegt da auf
dauer nämlich so eine wunde nase von es
tut irgendwann sogar sie beim pöbeln ja
wirklich
trotzdem werden meine kollegen und ich
nur noch gedacht weil wir natürlich
weiter zum friseur gehen müssen wir ja
wir müssen gut aussehen weil wir in der
öffentlichkeit stehen
es gibt ja keine hässlichen fußballer
mehr ich meine wenn ich busfahrer bin es
ist egal wie scheiße ich aussehe aber
wir sekunde im fenster meine branche
wird nur noch gemobbt der kollege toni
vom fc bayern war neulich einmal im
tattoo-studio klar war jetzt nicht so
clever von ihm das gleich zu posten
aber dafür ist das tattoo super schön
geworden
alle hacken auf uns herum wir mögen viel
schöner sein als ihr und viel reicher
aber wir haben trotzdem gefühle
denken sie da mal drüber nach danke sie
danke was ist deutschlands geknipste
beruf fragen wir die jury wie ist ihr
urteil
oliver welke das schwierig muss sagen
mich hat beides menschlich berührt mein
urteil ein klares unentschieden und
nächste woche treten gegeneinander an
ein h&m manager der vergeblich versucht
mütter und langzeitkranke mitarbeiter
aus der firma zu häkeln und ein
lufthansa-pilot der sauer ist weil sein
kurzarbeitergeld nur auf 15.000 euro
erhöht wurde
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los du
scheiße fährt